hello guys I'm Ryan right
say your name I am Anasazi of Bieber
housing I'm gonna stop seeing Bieber has
them and Ryan right today are gonna
watch a video that hey you just choose
one of these just choose one of these
this is all request um
if sex were honest if sex were honest
let's see what this video is all about
it's from BuzzFeed video looks like a
skit alright thanks for requesting this
guy's expensive I'm inviting you in
saying it's for wine but I really mean
sex I don't know where it stands
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll make sure that China doesn't smell
like cheese oh [ __ ] you're a sex tape it
down for this I'm gonna sex I'm gonna
have sex I don't want you to see my
thoughts but I do want you to see in
general taking your clothes off slowly
just in case your junk exterminated they
make me to control my facial expressions
that's why we're asking you about common
but it's actually just a phonology I'm
gonna get with my my name's Hannah only
fur that's to make your body but I'm not
making any promises
[Music]
Marilyn really hope this goes as good as
I want it to
I feel like you're related whatever but
I don't even think the honeymoon so
thirsty how's that mechanic why are you
laughing
it sounds nice I kind of like channel
okay I wanna cuddle too but if I go pee
I'm gonna get another UTI
baby you started laughing at the coming
part no I'm not gonna stop it you
laughed at the coming part okay
you faked it do you fake it pre I mature
ejaculation is not something to be
ashamed of premature ejaculate usually
I'm pretty good I have good stamina I
could I know I'm like the Energizer
buddy Danielle that's what she says
about me she's so sweet if sex were
honor you know honestly I had a hard
time truly relating with this video I've
never just had with someone my guy just
met and just had like a spontaneous
sexual experience yeah I've never I've
never done that like everyone I've like
had sex with is I've like known yeah we
should have brought her on this video
she can relate hard I felt like you
understand what it's like to go through
this the UTI thing I do get concerned
about I I heard that you must go pee and
the guys must do it too to clean out
their penis I knew someone who used to
every time they were done doing it the
couple they'd spray alcohol and they're
done it'll
why to disinfect oh that's a good idea
don't do it what do you guys need to
disinfect from baby lights slap a little
peanut butter on it and let the dog get
to work but only if it's organic peanut
because apparently I think that people
overcompensate and they take too much
minty [ __ ]
so not Brussels sprouts but like your
mouth sees like the dentist okay here we
need when she was talking about like I'm
taking off your pants slowly in case
your junk is small is that true she's a
big I thought she no yeah she's a big
but to hear because I'll slowly just in
case her jumpy there yeah in case
they're really weird yeah I mean I don't
know but I've heard stories yeah
wait are you guys careful with that like
what you're like I'm gonna take it off
slowly in case it looks weird the penis
bunker down and pray for day hunker down
and pray for daylight love my Stephanie
I suck at putting on condoms just to be
honest I've never been good at putting I
feel like I've always put them on the
wrong way did you see that condom velvet
spaghetti and meatballs no it's a funny
picture way to bounce off what I said
dad no that was really good back and
forth that we just say I'm sorry you
can't put a condom on correctly so I can
just show you how to try I keep doing
that
keep doing this sorry Brian do you want
me to show you how to do it here give me
that bomb you know what [ __ ] it get the
dildo get the dildo we're gonna do this
properly do you have a condom no no you
don't I think I have like a really old
condom in this box should we demonstrate
is there like a really old condom
this box which box all right hold on a
second guys we're gonna do an unboxing
video where do you go do you really have
something we can put it on though cuz
I'm serious or else we're gonna have to
get you on this no there's a fresh and
easy
all right Juba latex glove all right
[ __ ] it saran wrap and a rubber band
hold on a second saran wrap and a rubber
band
Oh baby got the jackpot it's called
basic now I don't know they've just been
in here for basic I've never opened to
combat this is so exciting no I swear
and someone and there's what what is
going on in here in this box I'm gonna
take this with me all right I know I
have yeah dude give it to your boy no he
needs it he's been stressed out give me
something for you to properly show you
how to do it yeah take your dick out yes
that's my girl here we go
shine the camera here we go oh I know
it's teaching young teens how to stay
safe oh my god it smells like fish why
are you smelling it stop that's like
three years oh okay so I think you take
the tip I really don't know but this
seems proper this is education for you
guys take the tip right really yeah
clench it it's just like in it to win it
and then you slowly put it over the
shaft don't go all the way you slowly go
over I'm gonna let go of that part there
we go here we go here we go okay wow
it's like my
oh my god Wow Thanks so then and then
they and then when you ejaculate it goes
into this bubble it goes into that
bubble guys see that this is how you
properly don't play my face and then
when you're done you just roll it up
looking for not keeping that you roll it
up baby I come here and show a pit out
might be a really big penis or basically
no it's not no don't break the condom so
we won't bring it in bring a ball
oh wait our car break-ins are totally
breakable what I'm talking about the
condom we only have two condoms left now
so many okay
basically you're supposed to make sure
that you squeeze this part called the
the ejaculation yes and you never want
to pull out too quickly what an
educational video you are wrecked after
if sex were honest anyway guys thanks
for - don't just throw it on the table
come on I eat from the table anything
penis and mountain Oh [ __ ] could never
have done it
Malibu baby can't throw that up
Daniel can you throw that I'll just
throw it up
so what feel like I'm 13 again Oh 13
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can click this button to subscribe
today danielle has an Instagram get
grammed up on Danielle on the Instagram
yo where she is just constantly saying
funny stuff
yeah funny slam [ __ ] sling [ __ ] oh
yeah she does a lot of BDSM kind of
videos 15-second long BDSM video make to
the point straight to the point
Kyle's point everyone hate this do you
ever like tie like a rope around Kyle's
penis and it's like slowly pull on it no
no don't don't look down as if I've done
it how are you gonna know you're just
stop down there I mean Brian is it